. We've previously talked about the reversing
of the yield curve, where you will have a
longer term bond that yields a lower interest
rate than a shorter term bond.
And as I explained to you before, hopefully
somewhat clearly, I always I'm never sure
if I'm actually explaining these things clearly
enough.
Typically, if you have the option of locking
up money for three years versus five years,
you would expect to earn more interest when
you lock your money up for five years because
you are giving up access to the money for
a longer period of time.
In exchange, you would expect to earn more
of an interest rate.
And when the yield curve reverses, what it
means is that the longer bond actually yields
a lower rate and it's a known sign of uncertainty
and a negative outlook for the longer future
of the economy.
If you're looking if you think the economy
is going to be a disaster over a five year
term, you may be willing to accept a lower
yield to tie up the money for five years,
because you expect that during that five year
period it may get even worse and you want
to avoid a potentially even lower return.
That's the sort of idea of a yield curve reversal.
We now have a different story, which is that
yesterday briefly and the numbers keep fluctuating.
The one in three month Treasury bills had
yields go negative.
OK, so understand what this means with treasury
bills and bonds, prices and yields move in
opposite directions.
So if you've got now we're talking nominally
magine a hundred dollar par value bill with
a 2 percent nominal interest rate.
If I buy that bill for 100 bucks and I get
$2 for each year that I hold it, my return
is 2 percent.
And then when I'm done, I get my hundred dollars
back for as long as I've held it, I've made
2 percent.
Great.
Imagine that the demand for that hundred dollar
bond goes up.
People want to buy that hundred dollar bond.
So even though it's one hundred dollar bond
or bill, you might pay $110 for it.
Meaning you pay 110.
You still get your 2 percent off of the hundred,
meaning your 2 bucks a year.
And then when you give the bond back, you
only get one hundred dollars back.
Remember, you paid 110.
You get 100 back because that's the value
the face value of the bill.
And you got your two bucks, your interest
rate, your your yield has now gone down.
And you have to, of course, account for the
$10 that you lost.
But then you made two bucks a year.
You can also add inflation in there and you
find out your real return.
When someone says imagine that the demand
went up like crazy and you bought a hundred
dollar bond for 200 bucks, it still pays 2
percent of the hundred dollars.
You're getting your two dollars a year.
But when you sell that bought, when you give
that bond back and you get the money back
out of it, it's a hundred dollar bond that
two percent may not have actually made up
enough.
You may be losing money in the net.
It would be an effective negative yield on
that bond.
Now, that's the concept of how yields can
be negative or positive.
Now, what we're talking about now is something
a little bit different.
Yesterday, the one month T-bill had a yield
of negative pointto 1 percent and the 3 month
had a yield of negative point 0 3 percent.
So how is that possible?
The math is that the yields can become negative
if the sale price of the bond goes super high.
Meaning people are desperate, desperate, desperate
to buy bonds, even accounting for the interest
rate.
You could be looking at losing money on that
bond.
You will lose money on the bond.
And what happened is that the Fed slashed
rates to zero.
So you're starting with a zero interest rate.
And there is such demand for a safe haven
for money that people are willing to pay to
have their money held in treasuries instead
of earning one percent for letting the government
hold your money, which is normally normally
the way it works is you give the government
money, you earn something for doing that.
When times are so uncertain, you might be
willing to pay the government pointto 1 percent
to hold the money.
Why on earth would you do this?
If you believe the outlook is so grim, knowing
you won't lose more than 0.01 percent could
be better when you're talking about large
amounts of money, that could be better than
being exposed to larger losses if you didn't
do this.
One other thing you won't necessarily actually
lose money with negative yields.
On paper, it's important to understand that
you could have deflation reach a point where
the cash payments from the bond are actually
worth the purchase.
Once you account for inflation, this stuff
doesn't really matter.
The takeaway is the most important thing is
that this is a signal about the insane level
of uncertainty that there is for the fourth.
Seeable future.
I think most of you probably understand that
that that's the most important bottom line.
And what this is connected to, of course,
are corona virus cases, accelerating unemployment.
The future of so many businesses in the United
States.
And that's where I want to go next